Well, it is great to be here and excited
to do this and thank you Armand for,
for putting that talk together.
Um,
I think we're going to have fun
together for the next hour. That's,
that's the goal is to learn, but also to
sort of have some fun together. So, um,
over the course of the today's our
conversation, we'll attend to do this.
We'll try to define urban technology,
explain really what we can achieve from
it and the really sort through some of
the challenges.
So in my mind,
I think we're thinking about this question
of how will it influence quality of
life? Why do we care, how do we measure
success and then how do we implement it?
Um, so most importantly,
our esteemed panelists, uh,
which we'll introduce here in a second.
We'll introduce how technology is
really sort of shaping their fields.
I think we've got an interesting
group of panelists, uh,
both representing sort of
community and development and arts,
a real estate development and obviously
technologist. So let me do this.
Let's introduce and welcome our panelists.
Um,
you have Google's very own Greg
Neville manning. Welcome. Uh,
Greg
is the CTO of sidewalk labs.
As you,
many of you probably know
sidewalk labs is an alphabet,
so bitaray applies people
centric to urban design. Um,
and really frankly is one of the,
the talks of the,
a really sort of one of those things
that people like myself, urban,
urban real estate developers and urbanists
or really sort of thinking about, um,
in terms of,
in terms of technology and how it will
have an impact really on our field and
what that means for us going forward.
Yeah,
I would jump in for those of you who
are fairly new, if you don't know,
Craig actually started the
Google New York City campus. Ooh,
that's why you're all here.
We also have Jonathan Rose.
Jonathan is the CEO of the rose companies.
Um,
which is a development company which
finds new ways to improve communities.
You know, both environmentally, socially
and economically. Um, rose companies have,
has developed a more than a hundred
projects, um, across the United States.
It is the 10th larger owner of
affordable housing across the country.
Um, in addition, Jonathan, um, is a,
is a recent author wrote
a really terrific book,
which I would recommend for
all of you to take a look at.
It's called the well tempered city. It's
a, it's a wonderful, wonderful book. Um,
so please take a look.
So join me in welcoming Jonathan as well.
We also have Elizabeth Goldstein,
who's the president of the municipal
art society, uh, here in New York. Uh,
the arts society has helped
New York advocate for
thoughtful and inclusive urban
design, uh, for almost 125
years or over 125 years.
And I will tell you that as we talk
about the ideas of displacement and
gentrification, a lot of the challenges
that cities like New York is facing,
the role of your team, your
organization, and what, uh,
the municipal arts society
does is critically important.
On prior to becoming the
president of that organization,
she was also the president of the
California State Parks Foundation and most
importantly has worked inside
government for really long time.
So as we talk about this
idea of implementing
technology into government and
getting government to sort of adopt this,
you'll have some great
insights for us as well.
So please join me in and also welcoming
Elizabeth to the conversation.
Yeah.
So you heard everything Steve's Steven
said and he's going to run the show.
But so many of you reached out saying,
you want to ask Craig and everybody
questions. I will have a dory going.
If you've got to go ask the panel, I'll
try to squeeze in a couple, no promises,
but uh, that, that's what I'll be doing
over here. So if you want to take it.
Sure.
So I think what's it start with an
opening panel cup question for all of the
panelists. And that is this, as
we think about urban technology,
how are you seeing technology factor in
to the longterm sort of vision and work
of your organizations? And maybe just
provide a really specific example for us.
Elizabeth,
we'll start with you.
Sure. I'd be delighted to do
that. I mean, I think, uh,
technology both has an extraordinary
ability to change and make our lives in
cities much better.
But it also poses some very significant
public policy challenges. Um,
if you just think about the sharing
technology and the controversy that's
existed around Airbnb, for instance. Um,
and even some of the carshare programs,
to what extent the city should yield a
spaces that normal people park in two
shared car services,
for instance,
is a question that wouldn't have
been posed a number of decades ago.
It just would never have come up right?
Cause the technology drove the ability,
forgive the pun, drove
the ability to, to um,
engage in that way. Uh, and
the sharing economy, um,
is obviously posting lots of challenges
from a public policy perspective,
both in a really strong and positive way,
but also in some ways that
are really challenging.
So, Jonathan, what about the work
that you do with your company?
How is technology impacting what you
all are doing out the communities across
the u s got it.
Okay.
So, first of all, we're,
we have a vast technological rethink
project going on now where we're committed
years and millions of dollars to thinking
about how we upgrade our systems and
data. And so I want to start with an
analogy and then I'll talk about how we're
applying. Okay. So the amazing, to me,
the model for everything is
nature and nature is, has a, uh,
you know, uses DNA is this
basic data system. But with the,
with nature actually does,
has an incredible ability to heal.
So imagine if there was a forest fire,
um,
nature knows exactly the small plans
to the medium sized planets and the big
plants in it. It knows how to
grow back a whole ecosystem.
And what's phases to do that
and the way we build cities,
we don't know how to heal.
So the question is, um,
and since we're tiered primarily working
in low income parts of cities and with
low income residents,
our question is how can we use data to
turn our static dumb ways that we run
cities and buildings and people and
systems now to make them dynamic
and responsive and reactive.
And ultimately co-evolving.
Great. What about you Craig?
The work that you all are
doing with sidewalks? A lot.
So there's a tiny bit of background,
sidewalk labs,
a form with express idea
of taking advantage of, of
technology in the cities and,
and figuring out how we might take a big
leap in terms of technology that cities
aren't maybe taking it completed on a job.
So one example of a technology that we
think this is slightly future looking,
we'll have a big impact and will come as
no surprise to you as his self driving
vehicles. Um, not just from the way
they will help people get around,
but actually even more so as their
impact on how urban planning gets done.
So just if you think about self driving
cars reducing or probably eliminating
the need for parking,
right?
Cause they'll drop people off and pick
them up and if they need to recharge,
they can go up to somewhere
where the people aren't. Um,
what do we do with that space?
Either an existing cities that's now kind
of along the sides of all our streets
and in our parking lots. Uh, how can we
use that space better for people? Um,
and if we're designing a
place from scratch, how wide
should the streets be? Um,
how should the space be allocated that
might've previously been diverted to
vehicles.
Um,
and so I think that has a number of really
far reaching consequences beyond just
my ability. It's, is this whole
idea of being able to reclaim,
I've been in the public
space, right. I mean,
that in my mind is one of
the exciting things about,
a little bit about exciting things about
autonomous vehicles is that for for
such a long time we've lost a big piece
of the public realm and we're going to
essentially be able to hopefully
claim some of that space back. Right.
So as we think about what you guys are
doing in Toronto, um, particularly,
maybe talk a little bit maybe about,
um,
as you think about the design of
the space in Toronto in a, of the,
of the project in Toronto,
what, what sort of other,
beyond autonomous vehicles do you see
technology playing a role to improve
living standards? Maybe you know,
from an environmental standpoint,
from even from just a traditional quality
of place standpoint. Absolutely. Yeah.
So, so this is a tiny bit of background
and sidewalk labs is really focused on
building a place, a brand new
place from scratch and Toronto,
right on the waterfront. It used to
be deport area of, of uh, Toronto, um,
over some amount of time and we're
still in the planning process and the,
and going through getting permission
from the city and the province of Ontario
and the, and the federal government
of Canada to go ahead and do that. Um,
but I hope for that area,
which has really undeveloped right now.
So it's almost Tabula Rasa is to
think about, as you mentioned,
sustainability sort of
environmental things.
How can we make this
place kind of positive,
so not just reduce the use of carbon
but reduce it to below zero, um,
through,
um,
clever applications of technology to make
heating and cooling more efficient to
non digital technologies like heating dis,
district heating and cooling,
which is often used on some campuses, but
expand that to a whole neighborhood. Um,
we think about mobility,
which I already mentioned.
There's a whole bunch of
really interesting things
even beyond self driving
vehicles there. Um, when we think about
buildings themselves, um, you know,
there are lots of technologies that will
enable and some already exist in some
form as to make buildings
much more flexible,
so able to adapt to
different users over time,
but also cheaper to build at the same
or high quality than we have existing
buildings. So the buildings
themselves and as you referenced,
the quality of the public realm,
uh,
each of these things contributes
to quality of life in the city.
And those are our goals. Um, but
in particular in the public realm,
if you think about it,
not just as parks, um,
but once you think about sidewalks and
streets and maybe start erasing the
boundaries between sidewalks and streets
and say these places are for people, um,
how do we make them much more usable for
a whole bunch of different activities
beyond what people use in for now?
Uh,
and really almost create a public realm
that's an extension of your living room
to make the whole place much more livable.
We think about also ways of supporting
more community and health and human
services. Um, and then sort
of underlying all of that,
how do we actually build
the digital technology that,
that ties us all together.
And there are opportunities there to,
to create less siloed systems than
currently exist within cities.
So what I'm hearing is this idea about
how we use technology really to really
push the envelope on sort of
people centric design, right?
Designers and urban developers
and people and mice are space.
I've been thinking about this a long
time but had been constrained by this.
But one of the things with,
with technology pushing the
boundaries a little bit,
we're maybe able to push the envelope
so to speak on this a little bit more
perhaps. Yeah, absolutely. And you know,
there are many things that, um, that,
that the main, the cities move more slowly
than technology does. Um, one of those,
for example, cities have
the responsibility to take
out the trash, you know,
on a regular basis. And if
that's, um, that's a, that's
a significant problem. Uh,
and so cities are unwilling to take big
risks and technologies, you know, at,
at Google and elsewhere. We build little
prototypes, we throw them out there,
we say, this is in Beta. If it
works, great, we will do more of it.
If it doesn't work, we'll shut it down.
Cities don't have that luxury. Um,
and so we hope that by creating a place
where we can actually experiment with
some of these technologies, um, and
prove that some of them do work, um,
then other cities,
it turns out that once CDC and other
city doing something successfully,
they're much more likely to follow along.
There might be some sort of leading cities
that we'll try it initially and once
there were a few than than,
than the way it happens.
And so our hope is to kind of bootstrap
that. I love that idea of replication,
right? This idea that you can take ideas
and sort of take it and put it in other
cities.
And that's why the project,
what you all are doing in Toronto I
think is really important. So Jonathan,
I want to go back to what you originally
said about this idea of thinking about
cities as organisms and particularly
why data is so important to us.
So tell us a little bit more about how
you sort of see data and syncing syncing
and scenario planning playing a role
to make us a much more dynamic planning
system,
maybe to make things more efficient.
So we plan in a 19th century way,
essentially maybe early 20th century
and then kind of, I feel, um,
distorted by in 1970 we passed
something called Neba and we have an
environmental impact statement process,
which just screws everything up as far
as far as I'm going and I'm going to
deepen environmentalist. So, uh,
and the reason is we can't
dynamically respond to anything.
So here's what I recommend
is that number one,
cities set visions and goals
for what they want to become.
And you can turn those into what are
called community health indicators and
community health indicators
are hundreds of measurements.
You can measure things like uh,
vehicle miles traveled and, and uh,
amount of walkability,
amount of affordability,
your climate impacts and how well kids
are doing in school and suicide rates in
the rest rates and all kinds of thousands
of measurements that measure your,
your vision of,
of what community health is.
Governments have tools and the tools
are basically regulations such as zoning
codes and building codes
and things like that.
Incentives and tax breaks and things
they can do to encourage people to do
things. And regulations discourage people
from doing bad things and they make
investments in things like infrastructure.
They can use those cool tools I believe
in a continually dynamic process.
So I'll give you an example.
We have a subway station and
we say we want higher density,
mixed use mixed income because we
want people to be able to walk to it.
And today we would come
up with some zoning,
but all these experts would figure out
what it should be and then they'd fix it
and to be there for 20 years.
And I suggest instead,
it'd be dynamic now with sensing we can
with big data and direct sensing and all
that,
we can actually see you,
the first building happens and you see
what it does and you keep adjusting. Um,
and so for example,
you create more,
let's say it doesn't look
like it's affordable enough.
So you create more incentives
for affordability and
let's say it's not that you
don't feel like people are walking in
offer and you can make higher uses of
retail uses that have encouraged
people to stay in the area.
There's a million tools that we have,
but we can be,
so we're dynamically continually
evolving towards our vision. Uh,
we have no capacity to do that right now.
Yeah.
Cause all of the data that we use in
this process is always looking backwards.
Right? I mean, right. For the
most part, we look backwards.
What happened over over time and
not really looking to the future.
I mean we tried to do that as as
as it's folks in the data space,
but we don't do a very good job of it.
So there's a new program developed by
an architect named Peter Calthorpe.
He's my brother in law. I got to reveal
that called urban urban footprint.
But what urban footprint
is a future casting system.
And so it's a scenario planning system.
So what I think you needed to be doing
is not only collecting this real time
data, but at the same time always
scenario, future casting forward.
You'll never be 100% right.
But the future casting,
the scenario planner give you a sense of
where to go and it'll give you a sense
of the implications.
And with artificial intelligence,
in essence you can use your
scenario planning and your
real time data collection
and keep fine tuning yourself towards
outcomes and just recognize we'll never be
perfect.
It's always evolving and it's dynamic.
So Elizabeth,
let's talk about inclusion and talk
about this idea of protection of local
characters.
As many of you as we talk about the rise
of technology in cities on particularly
cities like our, our hometown of New
York. Um, the question of inclusion and,
and displacement and really trying
to maintain neighborhood identity and
authenticity with technology coming and
fastly coming even more so in the urban
space.
It's,
it's interesting that we've been a
slow adopter in the urban space to see
technology, but as it comes,
how do we maintain the balance?
How do we make sure that we're
sort of protecting, you know,
that local character and being inclusive?
How do we do that?
Right. Well, I think, you know,
this is a huge challenge and um,
I want to reiterate something
that you said Jonathan, uh,
around the environmental process because
the environmental process in New York
City is one of the mechanisms that the
public is allowed to touch big planning
projects.
And it is,
I couldn't agree with you more about how
deeply flawed it is among other things.
We don't learn from that process.
So we gather all this data that the public
has interacted with in the course of
one planning project or
another or a particular project
that's coming forward in
a community.
And yet we don't ever learn whether that
environmental document wasn't effective
at establishing mitigations that
actually worked. So, you know,
humans fundamentally don't like
change. You know, we, we all, you know,
we all,
and I'm sure all of you live in New
York or where were you living around the
world?
You moved into a neighborhood,
you kind of had a sense of
what that was going to be like.
You chose it deliberately. Hopefully
you were able to, do you have the,
the privilege of being able to do that.
And you know,
the idea of that we could continually
change that without understanding what it
is, it's probably going to freak out
most, uh, most, uh, New Yorkers and,
and citizens. So the question is, how
do you create that level of engagement?
That data actually means
something to the citizenry.
So in New York City we collect a ton of
data and I'm sure everyone in this room
understands the concept of a government
Gov 2.0 and the fact that government is
not always the best provider of data
back to the public in a way that they can
understand it.
So one of the things that we need to
do and really in a very global way,
and my organization is confronting this
every day because we're trying to figure
out, well where is growth likely
to happen in New York? Um,
where does preservation efforts
need to be out in front? You know,
all those kinds of things.
It's really hard to figure that out.
And if you're an average citizen looking
at the data that's collected in New
York, it's very hard to get a
handle on what you're looking at.
So this interface between,
uh,
the collection of data and the,
purveying of that data so that
communities can actually engage in it is a
really, really, really important thing.
And it involves capacity
building in the community.
And this is a very human engagement.
It's not really about technology.
It's really about getting there and
helping communities understand what tools
they can reach for and how they can
educate themselves about how the system
works,
how they can engage that system,
where are the pressure points that they
can engage with and encouraging them to
do that and making sure that
in a governmental level though,
the playing field is as level as a can.
So whether you come from a poor
community or a rich community,
is your voice heard
equally in the process?
We all probably know what the
answer to that question is,
but that's probably for
later in the discussion.
So when we think about urban
planning, one of the, one of the law,
one of the biggest things that we
use to sort of dictate the way we,
that we offer, you obviously use
land. It's our, it's our zoning code.
Hi. Uh, there's industrials, there's some
land that's zoned for industrial use,
some that's zoned for commercial use
and some that is zoned for residential.
And generally speaking, cities
like to separate uses, right?
We like to separate uses because frankly
we like to keep things nice and tidy a
little bit. Right. That's sort of the
ideas for how we did it. That's right.
First Place. Um, so that said,
one of the questions that I have for you
all as we think about technology, um,
and this is a bit of a geeky question,
but it is,
how is the role of technology going to
allow us to really think about how we,
we rethink zoning in our,
in our cities and our communities crank.
You're probably thinking about this
really specifically in Toronto.
Some thoughts on that.
One of the specific things we're thinking
about is outcome based codes. So,
so to your point,
zoning and building codes tend to be
fairly prescriptive and static and say,
ah, you know, we know that in New York
City, uh, cast iron pipes for plumbing,
uh, what 20 while I'm already
safe. So that's, that's
everybody has to do that. Um,
and of course,
as technology improves,
there are probably a bunch
of other solutions that
maybe achieve the same goals
at lower cost store,
more flexibility and so on.
But because that sort of not on the
list of approved construction materials,
et Cetera, that are not an option. Um,
now with sensors and to your point
Jonathan, um, we can start saying, uh,
potentially, uh, let's monitor
it. Let's think about it.
Maybe an example of noise and one of
the issues around kind of having light
industrial next to residential as
maybe you're going to just do it.
People with noise, let's say that, um,
you can use the space for whatever
you like as long as the noise level as
monitored by some sense so that
it doesn't recall people talking,
but just the sound pressure level,
as long as it doesn't go above a certain
amount. And so you have to provide a,
a building and a set of uses
that dampens the sound and so on.
Uh, and that's monitored on
a dynamic, active basis. Um,
rather than saying there's just a set of,
of ways you have to build a building
because we know that that goes above and
beyond the standard. Um, and that's
true about all kinds of things, um, uh,
around odor,
around activities and so on.
So can you actually define building
codes based on the outcomes you want to
achieve and then allow
innovation to provide a new,
sort of a clever ways of achieving
those outcomes, um, and be
less prescriptive or about the way that
the codes are written. And Jonathan,
that's where that dynamic data plays
an important role to allow you to think
about those outcome metrics.
True.
Exactly. So the other thing is that
our culture has changed enormously.
If you think about it or
when America was founded,
I believe 90% of people lived on farms
whereby by the way, they were living,
working, manufacturing in effect,
doing everything all in one place.
And then we became more segmented in
industrialization was a very dirty process
and you didn't want to live near it and
it was to protect people. But today,
if you think about how most of us live
in work, it's in a very integrative way.
And,
and um,
although you may want to Madden a separate
significant heavy duty manufacturing
out, um, we really, the way people
naturally want to live now is,
is in a much more integrated way. And we
need communities that will reflect that.
So this week there've been three
articles alone about the rise of modular
construction,
right?
Modular housing construction as I sort
of technology and the development space.
Thoughts on that.
And you see that as an
innovative technology or
trend that will change how we
sort of think about affordability or even
the construction space as we developed
cities for the future.
Yes. So we're going to go near term part
term. Yeah. Okay. So in the near term, uh,
we've thought about manufactured
housing is creating chunks.
Basically boxes that you add up
and there's some advantage of that.
But then some also in flexibility, but
there's a company now, for example,
named dirt,
which is based in Canada,
which has a d I r t t is not
an advertisement for them,
but they have a system in which you do
three d design of the space that you want.
You put on cargoes and you can actually
walk and see through the space.
It's in real time giving you back
the pricing information. You're,
you're picking finishes, zero doing all
kinds of stuff. And then when you're,
you want to order,
you push order and then the factory
builds it exactly as it is and it gets
delivered to you and
never installation teams.
So you're really integrating design,
uh,
pricing and delivery. Uh, and it's much
more by the way, material efficient,
which is environmentally efficient.
Okay. But that's still at the, that's so,
and so those are walls and pieces.
So there's less than the chunk level,
but we're really want to go is member.
I started with the analogy of DNA.
So from an environmental point of view,
we have to move from,
we currently build out of
concrete, steel, glass, copper,
and all these we mined from the earth
and all have very negative environmental
impacts.
The true solution,
at least in the next hundred to 200
years to the environmental issues,
we have to start building out of timber
and organic materials cause timber
captions. Carbon has much
lower embodied energy, um,
and it's a regenerative material.
And for example,
we can already begin to grow fungus, like
kind of mushroom, like installations.
So the issue is we had the
move from mining in inorganic
materials to turning to
biological buildings if to start growing
our building materials. So to me, the,
the future step is where we're designing
our buildings in three d and then we're
turning that not into plans,
but we're turning that into DNA and we're
actually growing the components that
we need,
high tech components for our buildings.
And then when it's time to recycle
them or disassembled them, you can,
because they're the, they have a
basic code that we have created.
We can decode them and read and
repurpose them. And that's really does.
So it's following nature's cycle
as to how we're going to solve our
environmental issues and create a
much more affordable though. Right?
So let's just recap some of the things
that we've heard so far about technology.
We've heard that number one, technology,
the rise of technology and Everett space.
It's going to give us more
back of the public round back.
Perhaps it's going to make
us more climate sensitive,
really thinking about how
we think about the, uh,
the environment going in the future,
maybe more affordable housing. Uh,
may help with the inclusion piece.
One last thing we haven't touched on
enough is this engagement piece. So let's,
with what I know that you wrote a
terrific piece about, about how, um,
technology government is disconnected
a bit from the citizen jury.
How do you see us using technology,
particularly how can government use
technology to really engage with its,
with its community base at a much more um,
really authentic way?
Yeah, so I'm just going to tell
a little bit of a personal story,
which is that when I was in
government in San Francisco,
I often would hear from my employees
who had seen me on the cable channel.
I'm testifying before the
board of supervisors about
the budget or some policy
issue. That was before the
recreation park department,
which is the one I was
running at the time. And, uh,
I recently went down to a
BSA hearing, um, uh, sorry,
the board of standards and appeals,
um, in New York City. And uh,
not only is there no closed circuit TV
so that if you can't get in the room you
absolutely do not know what's going on
in that room unless someone comes out
with a Bull Horn and tells you in
the outer room what's going on.
There is no computer screen
that even says what items the,
the commission is, is on.
I mean literally we are in,
what is that 1980s technology
in terms of public engagement.
It also means that if you were a
citizen who radical new idea works,
you can't get to those hearings and
can't engage in the democratic process in
any substantive way. You have to take
time off, you have to get a babysitter,
you have to show up in a room where you
may or may not ever be able to interact
with the policy makers who are making
decisions. That is, you know, we are,
we are very, very far away from
the ideal let's just say but,
but let me just talk about a couple of
ways in which technology actually changes
very fundamentally.
So technology voting machines,
ability to do rank order
voting for instance is the
difference between us having
a walked in two party system and the
possibility of more minority views.
And I don't mean diversity views, but
just any kind of minority view, um,
beginning to percolate up in our
political system. So there is, and that's,
you know,
voting is the thing that New Yorkers
are not doing today that they should be.
Um, uh, and so we need to figure
out how that happens. This is,
this is the fun, most fundamental way
in which we engage with our government.
But when you move into these much more
complicated city planning and land use
decisions that are being made
and talked about, I mean,
I've been following the Toronto project
and the initial level of suspicion about
what your very thoughtful planning
process was really going to be about.
It's kind of understandable
because there's,
we live in a world where there's a
lot of distrust between government and
citizens.
And part of it is the sense that decisions
are being made behind closed doors.
So the question is how you open those
doors and how do you create a level
playing field so people
can engage in the dialogue.
There's a lot of technology tools to
do that. You know, people are using,
um, uh, you know, the ability
for people, for instance,
just to interact on a website or whatever
to put in their opinions and views on
a particular policy
decision that's being made.
But there's also opportunities in the
local community to really think about how
do we allow policymakers
to engage on a much,
much more incremental level
with their own constituents.
And I don't think that's what we're doing.
I mean,
tweeting is not a substitute
for real political dialogue.
I don't think anyone in
the room would doubt that.
And certainly in the last year and
a half, am I counting right? Um, uh,
we've seen how that's just
a destructive force in,
in a democratic dialogue rather
than a constructive one. So,
so really giving folks a mechanism for
having a true voice at the table. Exactly.
Sort remind you something
Austin's about yeah. About transportation.
Yes. Everyone's very excited. Um,
about the, the, the futuristic cities.
But I'm getting, tell me about my commute.
Oh yeah.
And I'm hearing like ride sharing services
have helped bike sharing services.
Like we have a few docs outside in
California and our offices there,
there's now a doc with scooters.
So how are we going to get around cities?
How will that be changing and mixed use
zoning helps in regards to the commute,
which we all talked about, but
what, what else is in store?
Well, I can I speak a little bit to where
we are in New York City at the moment
because I think this is a really
interesting question about technology.
So we are an environmentally strong
city because we use mass transit.
Um,
uh,
and our carbon footprint is much lower
because we do yet we have a subway system
which is in a state of,
depending on which day it is,
one might say total collapse
or partial collapse.
We have a brilliant new leader who
actually came from Andy, Andy Bideford,
who came from Toronto
actually who I have been.
I was very pessimistic about this and
he's been really causing my optimism to,
to rise.
He is deliberately picking a tool,
a tool for fixing our subway system
that is not the most cutting edge of
technology.
And it's very much to this point you
made a little bit earlier about does
government want to risk being
on the absolute front edge,
which many of,
you know,
governor Cuomo has been making an argument
that we ought to try a new technology
and our subway system and any bifurcate
to his enormous credit is saying not
until it's proven because I have to
deliver this fast and well and um,
I'm going to use the technology that's
been effective in other cities, right? Uh,
much better than the technology which is
now almost a hundred years old and our
subway system, but, but nonetheless
not at the cutting edge. Um,
and that gets to this dynamic about
whether governments can really truly adopt
the most cutting edge tool. I think, um,
we want him to actually make our subway
system work better in the next five
years,
which he says he is able to do.
If that's a trade off against a dream
of a technology that might take us a
little bit further. I don't know.
That's a hard trade off to make.
I think I want my eat train
to run faster sooner. Okay.
More thoughts on sort of the future of
technology and transportation as we look
to the future for,
for cities,
both from planning and maybe even
towards implementation. Jonathan hurt.
So, uh, the, the dream of autonomous
vehicles has an economics to it,
which we don't discuss much
and that is utilization, right?
So the car that's 24 hour utilized.
So by the way,
I've said to several of autonomous
vehicle makers and they've all ignored me,
that if I were going to roll out a system,
the number one place I do it is
in Las Vegas and the sunset strip,
because the weather's great
and the utilization is 24
hours is a very small rate
you've got to map at all is a very small
range that I would think that would be
like the most profitable street
in the world to do. But anyway,
um, but something, yeah. So, uh,
so maybe the mayor's listening,
hopefully, right. At any rate,
the point is all about you utilization.
So, uh, so when you, you guys
are too young to remember,
but when cable TV first got rolled out,
all the taboo cable TV sees it's covered.
He said to cities,
it's too expensive to go everywhere.
We are just going to start,
we want a franchise,
we just want to start in the places that's
most profitable and then over decades
literally they are ultimately
forced to do universal service,
which they don't really get away anyway,
try and get fire out in the
Bronx or something. But anyway,
which they theoretically you
know, have, have risen too.
So I see this as the issue that uh,
the autonomous vehicle
companies are going to say,
we want to be where it's most profitable.
And so you're going to be,
either you're on the loop
or you're in the system,
you were outside of the
system and rural America.
And does it mean a whole parts of
places in which there's in essence this,
this is the systems going to be biased
against because of profitable utilization.
And so if you really
want an equitable system,
the subway system is a really
equitable system. So I think, you know,
putting on a government hat in,
would franchise agreements you have to
franchise with a bias towards equity?
Are you suggesting that we have to sort
of think about the role of technology,
the future of transportation
even more as a public good,
continue to sort of think about it as a
public good even as we sort of mix and
mix and match the delivery,
a delivery vehicle.
So you have to think about as a public
good and you have to think about and and
so as a,
just as a founding premise of,
of all my another founding premise am
I thinking America is hugely zipcode
biased.
So if you live in the healthiest zip code,
you are 20 years statistically you are
likely to live 20 years longer than the
least healthy zip code.
And if you go,
if you grew up in the best public school
district or one of the top 20 school
public school districts,
you're a chance of getting into college
is literally a hundred times greater
than if you grew up in the worst,
maybe more than a hundred times greater.
So we have these enormous zipcode biases
in my theory about public policy is to
always, always overcome those biases
and equally distribute the landscape of
opportunity.
So in transportation,
which is the connectivity system
is one of those prime functions.
I basically say uh,
information, uh, healthcare,
education and transportation are the
places where you want the ground of
equality to begin.
Yeah.
Well I was going to say on the, on, on
the mobility side first I think, you know,
I've been sort of making the assumption
and I think the panel has in general
that self driving cars are coming.
I just want to just double
check that with the audience.
This is probably a
slightly biased audience,
but who thinks in 20 years there'll
be a lots of self driving cars sort of
everywhere. Okay, fine. So what,
so you guys are mostly bought in,
which is kind of what I suspected. Um,
one of the, I think the impacts of,
of self driving vehicles other than kind
of the mobility we already talked about
in the urban planning or
safety, you know, and,
and because these are computing devices
that are looking at older records at
once, you know, have lots of
redundancy. So you know, the
team at Waymo for example,
which was spun off from Google is has
got, you're working on very, very safe,
redundant computing, you know,
paying attention all of the time,
which is something that human drivers
just don't have the capacity to do, right.
And often choose not to do actively.
Um,
and so one impact of that is that we
have the opportunity to give streets much
more back to pedestrians and cyclists,
like actual people sort of wandering
around under their own steam.
And so I think one of the
other implications of self
driving vehicles is in fact
more walking, more cycling, more,
more healthy ways of getting around.
Another couple of implications are,
you know,
right now we have a vehicle fleet where
somebody buys a car for themselves
sometimes when they're commuting on their
own and then on the weekends they have
the whole family. And so thereby
sort of a larger vehicle than need.
Most of the time.
Um,
you would imagine a fleet of autonomous
vehicles might come in a whole bunch of
sizes.
In fact,
most of them will be relatively small
because it will be for individuals which
will also make things safer cause
sort of less mass moving around.
Um, but also less congested because
there are sort of smaller vehicles.
But there is,
there are some challenges.
I think this was not
an analog allied good.
You can imagine if it's super comfortable
to be on your autonomous vehicle
commuting and you can read the paper, you
can watch a movie, you can catch a nap.
Uh,
people might be happy just sort of being
in congested traffic a lot and kind of
just getting other stuff done.
And we might end up with cities completely
choked by vehicles. And you know,
it's not clear that that will happen.
But it seems like a high likelihood
that we need to think about the kinds of
policies and regulations around these
and maybe the kinds of market forces that
would not create that,
that dystopian future. Um,
and so I think there's some
really interesting challenges
ahead that aren't just
technological challenges but also,
like I said,
some sort of policy and
regulation challenges.
So Craig,
you were hit on a really important point
and that is public policy needs to be
thinking about these,
these challenges. Now this,
you had something that you wanted to,
no, no, I was going to go,
I was going to talk a little bit
about this dystopian view that he,
that you began with.
I mean,
Americans tend to think about
our cars as our personal thing.
Even in New York. And even
with car shoring, sharing,
we think about these
as our personal thing.
And if autonomous vehicles
are actually going to a treat,
achieve a utopian vision
and not a dystopian vision,
we need to let go of that idea.
Right?
Because it can't be one for
one or even one for four.
We just don't have the room for it.
And if we're going to garner back the,
the street and the sidewalk,
um, for the public,
we need not to have people believe that
they're an autonomous car is going to be
sitting outside their apartment building,
waiting for them whenever they want to go.
Right.
And that's exactly the public
policy challenge, um, uh,
that we have to confront is
against our, um, you know, our,
our other side, which is selfish and
once the maximum convenience we can get.
And so those,
those two things have to be balanced by
public policy and can they be balanced
by public profit policy
fast enough that the,
that the use of autonomous cars hasn't
said into a pattern that we then have to
break. And that's the, that's I
think the challenge of the timing.
How do we think through the public policy
issues soon enough that we're actually
implementing them along with autonomous
cars as opposed to after a po.
Autonomous cars have begun
to set patterns. Okay. It
cause that's an important point.
Public policy always tends to be reactive
instead of proactive are moving or
changing it. Which I think gets
to the point of why we need data.
Let's just shift the
conversation just a bit.
I want to talk about data privacy and
why we collect data. So Craig, you all,
what sidewalk labs may be,
thinking about how you're going to
look at data of your residents and the
businesses that are in your district,
what types of data do you think are you
going to be collecting and how are you
going to think about privacy?
You as you as you
mitigate these? Yeah, this is a,
this is an issue that lots
of people are concerned.
This is the issue of when we talk about
the planning and Toronto a little bit.
Yeah.
So the way we think about it as is we
always start at sidewalk labs with the
quality of life goals that we have and I
kind of listed things like mobility and
sustainability and public
realm and buildings and so on,
as kind of some of the things we want
to improve on in terms of public life.
And that's where we start.
When we think about data,
at least we don't think about data until
we've identified that we need data to
achieve certain goals.
So for example,
if you work through a goals
around sustainability,
around air quality and water quality and
energy usage for heating and cooling,
it turns out that the list of kinds of
data that you need like the flow of water
through pipes,
the flow of sewage through pipes,
the amount of energy consumed
by a building, uh, the,
the amount of heating and
cooling district wide and so on.
These don't seem like things that have
privacy implications. And in fact, when,
when you go down the list of
these quality of life goals,
it's not really clear to me where,
uh,
privacy invasive data at plays
a plays a role. Um, you know,
there will be other systems
somewhere else. You know,
obviously we all use devices
that in some ways, uh, you know,
asked war and gather our private data,
but it's not at all clear to me that,
that the city and the public realm should
be gathering personally identifiable
data.
Um,
it seems to me that we can achieve most
of the big leaps without doing that.
And furthermore,
I think there are ways that technology
can improve people's privacy.
So at the moment,
there's a bit of a silly example,
but if I go to a bar and I want to buy a
drink, not me personally. Uh, you know, I,
I was about to say, you know, the
bartender wants to check, uh, that I'm,
that I'm of drinking age,
I'm fine. But you know,
if somebody does ask for my driver's
license, I hand over to them my name,
my address, my actual, you
know, exact date of birth. Uh,
and there are technologies based
on cryptographic signatures,
essentially proofs of, of, uh,
of claims that allow me
that to demonstrate to the
bartender that I'm a drinking
age as certified by the DMV or some other
organization, but they can verify in a,
in a technological, logical way, uh, that,
that don't reveal any data apart
from the fact that I'm over 21. And,
and that's maybe a
slightly contrived example,
but there are many of these
cases where in fact we think, uh,
in cities you should be able to reveal
much less about yourself as you're going
about your daily life than you
currently are required to. So, Jonathan,
you've given a lot of thought to how
data should play a role in planning and
development. What about the privacy
issue from your perspective?
So it's a little more complicated
because one of the things we're really
focusing on now,
and we had this big partnership we put
together with the Harvard School of
Public Health,
Columbia School of public health,
Dartmouth and others to try and do a
baseline assessment of our residents and
see if certain interventions we're doing
on health and education to actually
make a difference.
And you can do that on a population level
and you can do it by measuring things
like hospital emergency room,
via ambulance, ambulances,
visiting your property
and stuff like that.
But what I really want to know is cortisol
levels and what are you known for as
measures of stress and what
really it is this stuff. You know,
I really want to know am I,
am I individually, you know,
how many people is diabetes,
have we reduced insulin levels
are improved or whatever. Um,
and that's complicated.
So I'll tell you the most interesting
technology we've come across.
We are not using this yet,
but we just discovered this is
there's a guy who measures um, uh,
basically human waste.
He did goes to city sewer systems that
he measures the level of cortisol in it.
There a batch of metal lights that show
how well you're digesting what you've
been eating and show whether you've
been exposed to environmental toxins,
et cetera. And that's a way we think
to be or we, so we need to find,
if not that system,
some system,
where are we going to actually
get human health real data,
but an an anonymous way.
That'd be a cleaner way to do it. Maybe
you were talking about cleaning your gun,
right? Yeah, for sure. I'll lose.
What should the community be concerned
about privacy as we think about data?
What's your, what's your thought from
the, Oh, I think the answer is, of course,
and you know, the, the issues
that we've just talked about,
both of Jonathan and Craig
have just talked about are
our examples of how it can
work in our favor, but without thinking
proactively about that, it doesn't,
it doesn't have to come out that way.
Right. And, um, you know, we, we,
um,
need to find ways to not only
create data that is an automized,
but useful for these
bigger societal goals,
but we also need to create data that is
accessible to the public so that they
know what everyone else is seeing.
Because part of the issue here
is transparency, right? Um,
is that it's doesn't feel good if
somebody else's collecting a bunch of data
about my community and I don't get to
see it and I don't understand what the
implications of it are.
Whereas if we can begin to
think about as we go along,
how do we make that data, which
will be largely innocuous, right?
Transparent so that people understand
where it is innocuous and where it isn't.
Um, uh, and then able
to intervene I think is,
it's a really interesting dynamic
that we need to think about.
But I also just want to
point out that that, uh,
a lot of the data that we're collecting
now isn't useful to government or the
private sector or to individuals at
all. You know, we sort of collect it,
but we don't,
we're at that stage when we don't know
quite what to do with it yet and how to
analyze it and how to make it
useful. And I think that, um,
uh, you know, we, we have been, we
met with a city council person, uh,
not too long ago when
he said, well, you know,
there's this phenomenon going on in my
neighborhood and it's only everybody
tells us it's only in our neighborhood
of these illegal conversions of housing
units. And we went to the public
sector data that afternoon,
pulled a big map of complaints that
are coming in all across the city.
And guess what,
it's not just happening in his,
it's happening all across the city.
And part of that is just the very simple,
um,
uh,
learning how to express that data in a
way that it's useful to policy makers.
So before we came out, Jonathan, you, you
post a really interesting question and,
and um, about this idea about enhancing
data to make us is enhancing data,
making us better consumers
are better citizens.
Talk a little bit more about that and
your thoughts and your thoughts on that
question.
So as you know,
you know,
my sense is the use of data by all of
the for profits and companies such as
Google's and many,
many others is all being used for
income optimization of the company.
And that essentially looks at
individuals as consumers and asks,
what can I either sell them or
facilitate the sales to them and,
and where is there money
to be made in that?
And that's the function of the
data and what's happened in,
in America and actually I'm seeing
globally is that people are, are,
are thinking much less about
their roles as citizens as there.
You mentioned the roles as,
as even voting.
And he does a really depressing article
in the New York Times this weekend about
it. A guy trying to do voter registration
and had Randall's island at a music
festival. And the, the, I hope everybody
in this audience has registered.
And if you're not registered to vote,
please register to vote and tell your
friends to register each hugely important.
Um,
and we are beginning to get the kinds of
governments that happened when we don't
care. Uh, or we don't care
enough citizen engagement.
So there's a measure of how you knew
what a really healthy community is.
And it turns out it's called collective
efficacy is whether people in that
community feel that acting together
they can make a difference and then
experienced the actual making
of a difference. And, and
that, by the way, it is,
it can be very data enabled.
We can use it to gather people
together to create movements,
to create information,
areas of interest. Um,
it's very different than
turning people into consumers.
Other thoughts? Yeah. And
well I also think there are,
there are big problems that
take big data and big, uh,
policy, uh, results. So, uh,
we were talking a little bit before
about climate change and I've been very
concerned about heat island in particular
because I think our, um, most of the,
the tools that are being used
at the governmental level,
certainly here in New
York or are very low tech,
they're white paint and trees. I
love trees. White paint is fine,
but it's not exactly a high tech solution.
Whereas if we were beginning to model the
natural wind patterns of New York and,
and zoning,
creating zoning and policy
implications for maximizing that,
we wouldn't be doing just a thing.
You know,
heat island means that we pump our air
conditioning and our cooling and all
those systems up, which of course makes
the problem worse. So I, in that case,
we've got an relatively old school
technology that's actually exacerbating a
problem rather than making it better.
Whereas if had combinations of scientists
and planners working together with
data to really think about,
well what are the changes we need to
make in New York City to really take
advantage of our natural systems
to cool the city in a better way.
We might actually be preventing
people from dying every summer,
which is what happens in New York. I
want to get a question from the audience,
right. I'll, I'll just put these
clothes anyway and on, on a,
on community engagement.
I think one opportunity is is you know
we talk about all politics being local,
but how about high political,
you know,
if I want to have a block party
and shut down my block, you know,
on the weekend and, and invite,
you know, you have some,
some folks along and play some music is
a big pulmonary process that the Mip d
it's, it's complicated and it said it
doesn't happen very often. You know what,
if it were possible for me to
say I live in this neighborhood,
who around me you sort of thumbs up,
thumbs down about having a block party
if you know the, if if things turn out,
you know if people liked the idea then
maybe there's an automated process for
that permit to be granted at as long as
there's no extenuating circumstances and
and the you make it much easier for those
things to happen and start by having
like a tiny bit of sort of low risk
democracy happening at a hyperlocal level
and sort of build up from there because
sort of that the stakes are lower and
things can happen a little bit
more quickly and and things,
there's more of maybe
instant gratification there.
I think there might be some opportunities
to start there and grow them to do
something more impactful.
I'm not sure if I liked that idea of my
neighbors will always say no question
from the audience.
Yeah.
So somewhere with that Jason has asked
re outcome based zoning rules at what
granularities do you plan to try this?
One could envision a mixed use
building where multiple tenants have to
collectively share a limit
on noise, odor, et cetera.
Do you expect to see new cap and trade
economies evolve within and or across
properties?
I think there's lots of interesting,
I've been questions with the idea of,
of of outcome based codes.
So I think we need to stop
by demonstrating that the
data can be collected.
And then I think yeah we,
there probably is some experimentation
about like what does it mean?
There are certain things that
I held that the life safety,
those are kind of nonnegotiable.
Those can't be sort of
negotiated within a building.
There are other things that are around
comfort and maybe our negotiated within a
building. Um, but um,
I think it's a new enough idea that
there's probably a number of iterations to
go through in a sort of a safe environment
before I think we understand exactly
what they should look like.
And of course it's in the end
it's a city regulation question.
And so the city has to be convinced
and that's a pretty high bar,
that this is a better solution
than the current fixed.
They also have to be able to
respond to that data, right?
I mean it's,
it's not just a question of the public's
willingness to engage in that data and
have it dictate a way,
an approach in a particular place,
but it's also the city's ability to
understand all that incrementality and how
it comes together and to be able to
regulate it in a way that's, that's
responsive to that. And um, when
you look in some our city agency,
it's one doesn't really think
that's going to happen tomorrow.
I just want to add,
go Jason.
That idea of a cap and trade economy from
the building level is a fantastic idea.
It could be an amazing marketplace
for environmental. Good.
One question before you wrap.
Kind of a question from Philip.
I think everyone is going
to be excited to hear this.
The panel talked about getting people
to think as citizens and get involved.
Could there be a 20% like project
for citizens to get involved?
What would that look like? How could, how
could they do that? It's a great question
from for the technologists in the room,
head down to city, that civic hall,
it's an old great organization here in
New York City where there's a physical
gathering of people thinking about these
problems and get involved in a project.
Uh,
we were actually trying to
do an initiative to get a
million low income voters
registered. Uh, I go back
to voter registration, but
once we get them registered,
uh, we need to inform them about issues
and it'd be great to do a 20% project to
figures out how you really inform people
about issues. So one of the things I
here, I mean hearing, just wrapping
up the conversation a bit, is it,
if we're linking about the role of
technology and the impact of the impact on
the future,
it's going to involve the engagement.
It's engagement from the technology side.
It's engagement from the development side,
but also engagement from the community,
right? That it can't just be top down,
that this idea that we have to look
to get our provide mechanisms for the
community to engage as well
as is it critically important
piece to this as well.
Please join me in thanking our panelists.
We are at time.
Thank you,
Steven.